Thank You flora I would like to thank
the organizers it's a very nice program
and very nice to be here so I'll talk
about a sort of new proof technique that
we have developed in the last year that
we call a special coupling and this was
developed through joint work mainly with
blood eager and underage or jus but also
through other words with the Mississippi
of death Amanda funny santosh kumar
Andrew Young and Henry Fister and also
sreenivas a few years ago okay so what
is spatial coupling special coupling
originated as an engineering
construction in coding theory for
building error correcting codes for
communications and it's quite old from
this point of view I mean it dates back
to 1999 and I don't know exactly the the
history very precisely rüdiger can tell
you more but maybe it was not you know
people didn't realize how how nice this
construction was at first and well
finally with progress that was made in
theory it was it was realized that
specially coupled codes achieved the
Shannon capacity for a wide class of
memoryless channel so so I'm talking
about LDPC codes and that that we are
going to specially couple that I'll
explain what what this is now for today
I want to my goal is not to construct
very good LDPC codes i'll study standard
LDPC codes however I want to determine
exactly their thresholds so what is the
if you wish the capacity for these codes
for the standard codes
and so we want to determine the
information theoretic limits of these
standard LDPC codes and i'm going to use
special coupling but as a proof
technique and in general it's a proof
technique that allows you to derive
properties of graphical models that have
nothing to do with this construction per
se okay so it's like when you use a
complex analysis to prove something in
real analysis you do a literal okay so
as I said I'll focus on one application
which is for those who know what this
means is the proof of the replica
symmetric formula for the mutual
information of LDPC codes or it could
have been low density generator matrix
codes but this set of ideas goes much
beyond beyond coding theory floor
already made some advertisement this
morning you can use it for a relatively
wide at least we think white class of
inference problems but also if I have
time I'll mention briefly some some new
algorithmic bounds on constraint
satisfaction problems like a case up for
locate so I don't know if I have timed
it okay so ruddiger briefly explained
what is an LDPC code so let me and also
what's the problem of communication
through a memory less channel but let me
briefly set up the notation here so LDPC
stands for low-density parity-check so
you want to communicate a codeword x1
through xn which takes values in plus
minus 1 and you communicate this through
a memory less channel so that makes
transition between so the code bit
excited that you send is received as a
symbol why I Q epsilon here is the
transition probability matrix so if you
think of a typical channel is
the binary symmetric channel where the
arrival alphabet is plus minus one and
so you flip the bit with probability
epsilon and you don't flip it with
probability 1 minus epsilon okay so
whatever I say is valid basically for
all so called binary memoryless
symmetric channels but think of this
channel as a typical one ok so these
these code bits that you send are
correlated through parity checks here
that so these are modular two sums in
the 01 language of the bits that are
connected here and in the language of
plus minus 1 in fact the so the
constraint that joint force is that the
the product of the i'll call them spins
of the spins that entering the parity
check should be equal to plus 1 so this
model here you can view view it as a
spin system when you do inference you
want to decode according to the say you
want to the code according to the map
optimal estimator so so so you have to
study this measure over the spins x
given your channel observations y and
and this measure is the measure of some
kind of spin system where you enforce
the constraints here the product of the
the spins should be equal to plus 1 so
this is the gate or function for this
product and you have a prior measure
over the spins that in fact contains the
channel the knowledge that you have of
the channel output ok so so the channel
outputs why I are are encoded or
parametrized by by the by this log
likelihood ratio H I that you can think
of as a magnetic field that acts on
spins and has a tendency to polarize
spins up or down so that's your prior
information
ok so the code has a rate that I will
fix the rate is fixed by 1 minus the
ratio of the left degree to the right
degree the left degree is a degree of
the so-called variable nodes here and
the right degree is the degree of the
check nodes so think of degree 3 6 & 3 &
6 here so the rate is one happy so what
I want to do is to fix the degrees so
these corresponds to standard regular
LDPC codes and I want to look at phase
transitions for this measure as the
channel noise epsilon the bit flip
probability varies so so what kind of
phase transitions do we have we have two
types of phase transitions basically one
that I call static is the thermodynamic
phase transition of statistical
mechanics is the optimal threshold from
the point of view of information theory
is defined as follows epsilon map is the
smallest value of epsilon such that the
average over the ensemble of LDPC codes
I i forgot to say so these codes are
drawn at random from some ensemble with
fixed degrees for variable and nodes and
check nodes so this average Shannon
conditional entropy of the input given
the output when it is strictly positive
you cannot decode them but when this
vanishes in the asymptotic limit you
expect that you can decode so there is a
phase transition typically such that
from zero to epsilon map you can decode
this average entropy vanishes and above
epsilon map you cannot decode this
average entropy that's not vanished so
if you are not used to
an entropy here you can also think of H
as the log of Z so minus the free energy
of the obvious okay the second phase
transition I want to discuss is an
algorithmic phase transition at least
when you use message passing so belief
propagation that's the maximum noise
value such that the belief propagation
decode decoder can recover the input and
certainly you have in general that the
algorithmic threshold is less than the
optimal threshold however the basic
questions that I want to answer is can
one compute these thresholds exactly can
one even compute this conditional
entropy in the asymptotic limit and can
one do this even rigorously okay so the
main result here that I want to explain
how we we prove it with this proof
technique special coupling of the proof
technique combined with interpolation
methods is the following theorem so I
will need some technical conditions that
say that okay the degrees of the code
have to be constant the degree of the
parity checks has to be even I will say
why later and also I have to take a
large enough degrees but finite fixed
that's still large enough okay under
these assumptions one can prove that
this limit of the conditional entropy
the average condition length of the
averages over the quadrant humble is
given by a variational problem and this
variational problem involves a
functional of some probability density X
that I don't specify for the moment I've
specified later and what you should do
is compute the supremum of this
functional over the
probability density so now for a few
slides I won't write down the formula
because it's it's a bit complicated even
to explain the formula but later on will
become a bit more technical and i'll
give the formula in more details but for
the moment we just need to know that the
theorem says you can compute this as the
supremum of some functional over some
set of probability densities and
moreover all the thresholds not only the
map threshold but also the belief
propagation threshold is contained in
this functional so if you study this
variational problem you can completely
that reminder the thresholds now this
functional was first computed by
statistical physics method that goes
under the name replica symmetric
calculation and so it's called the
replica symmetric functional alcoholic
ladies and this was computed around the
year 2000
ok so the predictions of this formula
are the following so basically this
curve here as a function of epsilon is a
continuous function so it is it is 0
from epsilon equals zero up to epsilon
map that's the information theoretical
optimum threshold and then it's positive
but it's always continuous so epsilon
map is a point where the function is not
analytic since its 0 and then it's
positive at epsilon map it's not
analytic so there is a question what
kind of not only analyticity you have ok
so i'll be interested only in cases
where in fact i have a first derivative
in the jump of this function I mean a
jump in the first derivative of this
function ok and this is called the first
order phase transition and this is
always the case that the first
derivative jumps when the degree of the
variable nodes is greater or equal to 3
ok for L equal to 4 a degree to that's a
special case where the phase transition
is continuous so it's a higher
derivative that we jump so ok this case
is also covered by N by by your methods
but that's not the really interesting
case that we want
okay so now we will use in our proof not
only special coupling but also older
tools that have been developed okay and
there are two basic inequalities that
have been known for a very long time I
mean a long time means ten years so the
first inequality in fact is a lower
bound where that says that this this
quantity I'm after the this conditional
entropy is greater or equal than the
soup of this replica symmetric
functional okay so of course for many
years we've been frustrated because we
could not prove the converse bond and
this thing here you know the methods to
prove this bounder I won't show them but
they originated in the work of gua and
Tony Nellie and go under the name
interpolation method these are the bombs
that were first proven for the escape
model and then extended to sparse
systems he said BBC codes are spin
systems on dilute graphs by hands and
Leonean panchenko and then this made its
way into coding theory okay the second
bound is a kind of intuitive bound
although for codes it's not at all a
trivial bound here but basically it says
that the map decoder is better than the
beef propagation decoder so
mathematically you have the following
thing if you look at the derivative of
this conditional entropy with respect to
the noise of the channel and take the
limit this is less or equal then the
partial derivative of this replica
symmetric functional with respect to the
noise so in this object that i'll write
later on you have an explicit dependence
with respect to the channel so you can
take this partial derivative with
respect to this explicit dependence but
you also have an implicit dependence in
the in the in the max you know the soup
in fact is attained done in this max
density that maximizes this you have an
increasing dependence so I don't take
the derivative with respect to that to
this implicit dependence here so okay
well in the case of the binary erasure
channel where a bit is sent and either
it's received or it's erased so that's a
very simple channel and Whitaker was
talking about that channel these two
objects they have a nice interpretation
in fact this can be interpreted as the
probability of error under map decoding
and this can be interpreted as the
probability of error under BP decoding
and then the inequality is basically
evident however for general channels you
don't quite have this interpretation as
a probability of error here so it's not
a trivial inequality from the point of
your spin systems it can be viewed as a
kind of correlation inequality for
magnetizations in coding theory you find
the other proofs that take some
different one to leave ok so now if we
didn't have a phase transition in this
problem or if the phase transition was
continuous like for codes with degree 2
for the variable nodes then just by
combining these two inequalities we
could essentially close the gap here and
get the Equality ok so you get a lot of
insight from this remark for for what
follows so I just want to to go through
this remark
all we didn't have a phase transition of
first order or not no phase transition
at all then what would happen is that
with no phase transition in fact this
this replica seabed functional would
have a unique maximum and you know as as
the noise varies this maximum would
would vary continuously but would not
jump from one value to to the other one
when you have a first order phase
transition it happens that this max can
jump from one value to to the other one
now if this max does not jump from one
value to the other one anyway you can
you can replace it by by the so you can
replace here so the max obtained by the
BP decoder you can just replace it by
the soup so you can finally and and then
you can replace this partial derivative
by a total derivative ok so the
inequality without a phase transition
that's also true if you have a second
order or higher order phase transition
you can you have here two derivatives to
total derivatives and if you have to
total derivatives then basically you
could you can integrate the inequality
from zero to epsilon on both sides and
you can do this integral and then what
you get is that well the integrand i
mean the thing inside the derivative at
epsilon minus the thing at zero noise
but a zero noise this entropy zero
because you have perfect knowledge so
finally you get on the left hand side
this conditional entropy is less than
what's in the derivative here and this
you can check explicitly a zero noise is
also zero so you get this inequality but
this if you look at the
guava type inequality here is exactly
the converse inequality sign so so so
with two inequalities you get equality
okay however when you have a first order
phase transition you cannot replace this
this partial derivative by a total
derivative okay so this doesn't work
yeah so so maybe I should have shown
this graph before so that's exactly the
case where I'll have a social so this is
a cartoon picture of this replica
symmetric functional that depends on on
densities here well you can picture the
density here as a real number and so i
plot i plot minus the replica symmetric
function like i call this a potential ok
like feces prefer to do cloud- this
thing so it's a potential this as a
function of X here and you see when you
have a first order phase transition as a
function of epsilon this family of
curves develops a local minimum here and
and that's why you cannot replace what i
was saying here this this belief
propagation maximum is belief
propagation maximum corresponds to the
local minimum and you cannot replace it
by the soup or by the true minimum the
true minimum is here at zero ok when you
go down to the mat threshold the map
threshold corresponds exactly to the
situation where the two minima are at
the same height so that the true minimum
jumped to this other value that takes
over and becomes the neutral minimum so
that's the first order phase transition
okay now with special coupling in fact
what we will do is that somehow we will
eliminate this local minimum okay by
eliminating this local minimum we'll be
able to carry out basically this
argument so that's a first idea of how
things work so what is special copying
ok so this construction as i said is an
engineering construction was introduced
by first home and the ganga and so what
you do here is that first of all you you
align along the chain a certain number
of LDPC code am humbled so that's a
cartoon picture for a set of 2 l plus 1
LDPC code ensembles so i have the
variable nodes here and the check node
here and variable nodes have degree 3
check nodes have degree 6 ok so at each
position you have a code ensemble so you
have to imagine here that you have a
stack of variable nodes here in this
direction and here and and this is just
a cartoon picture for the edges that are
connected along your graph that is here
so you align this for us and then you
reconnect the edges so that the various
codes here get couple but somehow you
you preserve the local degree structure
ok so this can be a technical
constructions especially if the degrees
are constant Ellen are you have to
satisfy a lot of constraints so so I
want to explain this technical
construction what is important is that
somehow you have more check nodes at the
boundary here so the bits that are at
the boundary are more constraint so the
arm they are better protected ok so
intuitively when you are going to
to to run the beef propagation decoder
these bits at the boundary will help you
okay the checks here at the boundary
will help you because these bits are
better protected and these bits act as a
kind of of seed that allowed to find the
code word at the boundaries and then and
then you you sort of find the code word
by entering I mean the seed propagate
inside the system and you you can decode
okay so that's just an intuition but
this intuition tells you that basically
you know the correct minimum of the of
this replica symmetric functional will
propagate inside the system okay and in
the bulk maybe you are stuck at the
wrong minimum but somehow if you
propagate the correct minimum width so
suppose the noise is is is fixed and and
you have this dysfunctional here this
potential functional if the correct
minimum that is at zero propagates
inside the system and in the bulk you
are stuck here the effective potential
that drives the decoding during the
coding in fact you should really think
of it as a kind of convex convex
ification of this potential so so your
your effective energy here is a convex
combination of this point and this point
okay so so you have it effectively
complexification of this potential and
and so you can find always the correct
minimum that's also one way to think
about the problem and that's called the
Maxwell construction in physics okay so
that's what I'm saying here for these
calls here the local mean for the
entropy it's a local max so sometimes I
change words between Max and min but
this local thing disappears the
metastable states disappear and the new
VP threshold the new
algorithmic threshold of the coupled
codes becomes basically equal to the
optimal threshold okay because if you
think about it if you can't vexa Phi
this card of here well we need to draw a
tangent here when when you increase
epsilon you will reach these tangents
will reach the auras on thohir line and
and and and there is no more bp
threshold in fact okay or the BB
threshold is exactly equal to the map
threshold when the tangent becomes a
result of okay so that's a basic
intuition now I want to make all this
more quantitative so it's going to
become a bit more technical so to make
things more quantitative I just need to
introduce a few definitions here so let
me first describe the belief propagation
algorithm so the belief propagation
algorithm we already saw in this
conference in fact exchanges messages
along the edges of the graph according
to some update rules here and thanks to
these updates rules you compute an
effective log-likelihood associated to
bit I that you want the code and this
log likelihood you can compute the kind
of marginal of your measure that's the
BP marginal and then you take your
decision according to this marginal
weather is H I at time T is positive or
negative you fix the bit to +1 or or
minus 1 now this algorithm is tracked by
something called density evolution so
density evolution tracks the density of
messages along the edges of the graph ok
so so this X in fact is exactly the
density that I have in my replica
symmetric functional over which I have
to optimize
but here it has nothing to do with this
replica symmetric functional for the
moment it's just the density of the
messages along the graph and this
density satisfies the density evolution
equation which in fact is written here
in a rather abstract way but what it
means here is that you make a
convolution l minus 1 times that
corresponds to this sum here and then
there is another sort of boxed
convolution operation or minus 1 times
that corresponds to this product of
hyperbolic tangent an arc tangent here
and then there is a final convolution
with a channel density which corresponds
to the sum of H I plus the rest here ok
ok so now density evolution is
initialized with a Dirac that's centered
at 0 filled with no knowledge about the
spin and we know how to prove that it
converges to some fixed point x infinity
when you start from here ok so x
infinity is always a fixed point when
you start from no knowledge about the
field and if you converge to the fixed
point Delta a Dirac Delta at infinite
field then these pins polarized and you
can decode ok so the formal definition
of the BP threshold is the highest
epsilon for which this fixed point here
is the Dirac mass at at infinity so that
you can decode and beyond that you
cannot decode with certainty or you're
ok now this algorithmic phase transition
is best viewed on a curve that I call
the belief propagation exit curve ok I
don't explain the terminology here but
basically what is this curve so you
consider this BP marginal and you look
at the entropy
so this BP marginal is fully described
by this this log likelihood that has
some some density that you find
according to dance evolution and you
look at the entropy of of this object
basically the average entropy of this VP
marginal so the Shannon ever the Shannon
entropy of this marginal averaged still
averaged over Y and this is this H here
and you differentiate with respect to
the channel noise but you take a partial
derivatives not the derivative with
respect to the internal dependence you
so that's called the BPG exit curve okay
this BP Jack the curve is exactly equal
to the thing that was involved while we
see we'll see later on it's exactly
equal to this partial derivative of the
replica symmetric functional
so that's a nice object to describe the
the algorithmic threshold below the BP
threshold discard vanishes so it's a
vanish identically and above the BP
threshold typically it jumps and it
doesn't vanish okay now I need to
describe this static phase transition
the thermodynamic phase transition so
this description is based on this
replica symmetric prediction of
statistical physics so this replica
symmetric method allows to compute is
functional here and this functional is
written exactly can be written in terms
of these convolution operations that act
on densities so so the circle
convolution is usual convolution the
boxed convolution corresponds to some
product of hyperbolic tons tons
functions and things like that so you
don't have to fully understand this
formula but basically this replica
symmetric functional is a sum of three
entropy terms one entropy term is
exactly the entropy term that was also
involved in the belief propagation G
exit curve and the other two entropy
terms do not depend explicitly on the
channel they just depend on this dense
DX now when you want to compute this
soup you look at the stationarity
condition of the density evolution of
this functional and you get exactly this
density evolution equation in the form
of a fixed point equation this was the
equation that tracks the VP algorithm
just in the form of a fixpoint equation
okay so this equation here if you view
it in an iterative way so it's exactly
density evolution you can also think of
it as well because because you know
because this corresponds to minimal
while maximizing dysfunctional or
minimizing minus the functional you can
view this equation as basically gradient
descent along this potential this
potential is minus the replica symmetric
function okay and when you you run
density evolution if your noise is above
the VP threshold you cannot decode
because you will get stuck in a local
minimum here below the BP threshold you
can the code because you go down here ok
so now and the map threshold corresponds
to the to the situation where the
minimum jumps discontinuously from here
to here okay so it's exactly the
situation where epsilon is such that
this family of curves here varies such
that when epsilon equals epsilon map
this curve touches exactly the
horizontal axis and the two minima are
equal so the prediction of statistical
physics is that this epsilon map is
exactly the epsilon where this curve
touches the horizonte axis well it's a
prediction so for the moment I just make
a definition I call epsilon potential
this epsilon where the gap here goes to
zero so the highest epsilon such that
the gap between the true minima and the
local minima minimum goes to zero
okay and of course we will prove in the
process that really epsilon map equals
absolute potential okay just as I had a
BP exit curve we have a map exit curve
and this map exit curve is just defined
like that you take this conditional
entropy averaged over the LDPC ensemble
after and and and I differentiate with
respect to epsilon i take the asymptotic
limit nederland soup if i don't know yet
the limit exists in fact these limits
can be proven to exist at the end okay
and when epsilon is less than epsilon
map this curve is 0 because the entropy
is simply 0 and when epsilon is greater
than epsilon map the entropy is nonzero
but as I said before the first
derivative jumps so this curve jumps and
then it's monotone increasing as you
increase the notes
so I come back to this theorem now I
have introduced a few tools to start
proving this theorem so the theorem that
we prove goes as follows first we prove
somehow that epsilon map the map
threshold the optimal information
theoretic threshold is equal to the
potential threshold that's calculated
from from this potential function and
once we have proved one then there is a
very easy argument to to use this
equality now okay and as I said before
for many years we have known that the
second thing here we have known that we
have a an inequality in this direction
ok that's the Guerra type interpolation
bounds and this Guerra type
interpolation bounds also implies that
for the first point you had the
inequality in this direction so an upper
bound on epsilon map ok so we have known
these two bounds for many so now I'll
prove the converse bound for that and
then we can build so let me very quickly
show y 1 implies too ok and so I start
again with my integration argument just
like before so take the map exit curve
so that's the derivative of the
conditional entropy and now I ain't it
so before I showed how to integrate it
from 0 to epsilon but this does not work
when you have a first order phase
transition you cannot go past epsilon
map or even you cannot go past epsilon
BP so now I in any case since the
entropy is 0 below epsilon map that's
not the interesting regime really so I
look only above epsilon so let me
integrate from epsilon map to epsilon
since that's a total derivative while
you find this
the function in the derivative minus the
function at epsilon map but at epsilon
map since the entropy just below epsilon
map is zero and since I know it's
continuous this you have to prove
independently then it's zero at epsilon
map so we just find this ok now let me
take the belief propagation exit curve
this belief propagation exit curve as I
said before is defined simply as this
partial derivative of the entropy of the
of the BP of the entropy of the of the
BP marginal ok now if you look at the
replica symmetric entropy if you want
you cannot remember the formula but the
formula contains this quantity plus two
other terms that do not depend
explicitly on the channel noise so the
partial derivative will not carry on the
other terms ok so you can put here the
replica symmetric entropy and now the
point is that you can since once you put
the replica symmetric entropy since you
computed as the at the belief
propagation fixed point and this belief
propagation fixed point is also a
stationary point of the entropy you can
replace the partial derivative by a
total derivative because the total
derivative will act partially on this
epsilon so that's the partial derivative
but it will also act on this x infinity
but how does it act on x infinity first
you differentiate with respect to x
infinity and then you differentiate x
infinity with respect to epsilon but the
derivative with respect to x infinity is
0 because X infinity is a stationary
point of this functional so you can do
this and that's where we need
technically that the degrees are large
because to play this game you need to
control some regularity
how how does x infinity depend on
epsilon it should depend somehow
regularly an absolute to be able to
differentiate somehow so that's where we
need that degrees are okay but once this
is done since this is a total derivative
then it's a good idea to integrate it
and when you integrate it you find the
replica symmetric functional at x
infinity minus this replica symmetric
functional at the potential threshold
but by definition of the potential
threshold this is zero because the
potential threshold was when when this
function touches the horizontal axis
where the two minima are equal and now
this now is any way less than the
supremum over x of hrs okay now remember
that we had this inequality here that
states that the map decoder is better
than the belief propagation decoder
that's a completely general inequality
so you take this inequality you
integrate over the interval epsilon map
to epsilon and absolutely essential to
epsilon on both sides and you use these
these inequalities here and then you get
the converse of the interpolation bound
you get exactly the converse of the
interpolation bound so we are happy
because since we have this bound and the
converse population bomb we have the
equality okay so i just showed why one
implies to okay and now a special
coupling will be used to to prove one
okay
okay so so we just have to prove one as
I said and this will be done by special
coupling now because of the old guerra
type bound we know that epsilon map is
less than epsilon potential so by
special coupling will prove that epsilon
potential is less than epsilon map and
this inequality is proved for the
standard LDPC codes that have nothing to
do with specially coupled code okay
special coupling is just a tool that we
go around okay so what's the main step
of the proof is to construct this
ensemble of spatially couple codes that
I vaguely explained before so we are
line 12 plus one here ensembles of
standard LDPC codes and and we couple
the codes in such a way that we create a
seed where the bits at the boundary are
more or less known and because they are
known the belief propagation decoder is
good at decoding and there is a decoding
wave that propagates through the system
and you can control this process and
prove that when the length of the chain
goes to infinity first and then the
width of the coupling so W here is a
parameter that measures the width of
this coupling so if you take a position
up these this position is coupled up to
W position on the left and on the right
side so when we take the limits in this
order L goes to infinity and W goes to
infinity well then this belief
propagation threshold goes to be
absolute to the potential threshold okay
so i guess i'm not sure time so not very
okay so I completely skip this is proof
the second element now is to show that
for this specialty couple system the
information theoretic threshold the map
threshold does not change okay so this
we do by a variant of the interpolation
method so we interpolate somehow I'll
summarize this very quickly we
interpolate between this couple system
and a completely disconnected system
that's here on one side and on the other
side we interpolate with another system
where the coupling window is as big as
12 plus one here so that's a completely
connected system that's equivalent to
basically L disconnected systems and we
do this again by some kind of variant of
the interpolation methods and so we
prove that this conditional entropy for
the couple system is equal to the
original conditional entropy so then of
course the map threshold of the whole
system is equal to the map threshold of
the original system okay and so I'll
skip the proof ideas of this
so and now we put everything together so
that's where things hopefully happen and
become clear so we proved by special
coupling that the BP threshold of the
special acabo system is equal to the
potential threshold now because this is
an algorithmic threshold it's less than
the map threshold of the top old system
by one variant of interpolation this map
threshold of the couple system is equal
to the map threshold of the original
system which by this old guerra type
bound is less than the potential
threshold okay so basically all these
thresholds are equal and in particular
the map threshold and the potential
threshold are equal okay and this ends
the proof of this of this theorem so
since my time time is up I'll conclude
here now this these ideas can be applied
as i said to potentially many other
inference problems other graphical
models and we already have some
applications to the problems that flaw
show this morning but we also have some
applications to proving lower bounds
better lower bounds for the case at
problem that for k equal 3 these are
successful lower bounds that are better
than the currently known lower box
ok the next LOL down or the satisfaction
special yes so for k equal three we can
prove the satisfiability threshold is
bigger than three-point 67 the previous
lower bound in the literature is
three-point 52
you can thank you very